you welcome to this video playing
Barracuda let's see how I fair here yeah
I really have some issues with my new
mouse the problem is that i have a hard
time to set it up correctly this thing
has so many things that you can actually
change like I mean I don't even know
what it means like DPI rates and whatnot
and um yeah okay i hope i have I now
have a setup that is ok but I'm still
I'm struggling with that okay so we
gotta buy your net IAM um p and now a
five the c-5m takes Knight takes bishop
b6 and 85 hangs am and how do you play
this here some rook a3 maybe 92 93 maybe
this year getting the night over there I
don't know night to be three and then a
five hmm yeah no expert I just wanted to
try something else here with the bayonet
but he's also taking his time I mean
c-5m that looks kind of normal mmm okay
let's just put it on B to the move
rookie 8 isn't the most um helpful move
anyway he has to play rook f8 probably
again then 98 then f5 this kind of thing
may be king okay it's also possible but
okay I don't think he really wants to um
okay I mean really wants to take on d to
this is some pretty bad a DM okay let's
put this back the bishop is really silly
looking
them on be too it might support a future
f form okay that's just the tech d6 it
cannot be bad really asks wide what is
going to do about this we probably not
have six back if he goes snider to f6 I
might have f4 by the way okay he's just
retreating so maybe rue k3 that's often
a good idea okay it's totally not paying
attention to my moves again but that's
what they usually do okay I thought that
rook h3 might be something to worry
about okay I can get back to g7 er
that's true okay I can just take it
should be first move to check one
interesting question is how is going to
recapture it's not not clear-cut night
ich sie probably play 94 yeah this looks
risky but probably it is ok oh yeah I
wonder if I should just go ahead form
and tear open belong diagonal
and form Bishop takes rook chicks EF I
just need to get the Queen over to the
long diagonal and this is totally
falling apart hmm interesting you can
also go here it's maybe an idea it's not
clear where the bishop is going it goes
back to g7 I really have a form and his
king is just shaky I think okay I
thought that should be totally
unplayable Bishop takes T to the dark
squares look look totally totally dead
now okay let's just go and fall if
that's not right something is it sim
simply simply strange so right f4 f4 f4
Quincy three I mean how do you survive
that one let's see
okay I could have played just queen age
six actually I'd what's strong as well
without any sacrifices but ok this it
really should be should be good for
white so Quincy three ok I have 96 if
everything else is failing just one left
there's something better can also just
move the Queen and attack this rook
queen of three for example it's not
particularly bad but if i take the six
queen d 6 25 texts exo-k for Bishop a
form chap that's just good form ID so
let's do that to be careful not to fall
totally behind on time important this
Bishop c7 that's an important little
detail that I will always be able to
grab the pawns or tie them to the
defense of the pawns ok so I'm just
taking here right
check on a one king of 295 this is some
kind of counter play I don't think it is
any dangerous okay here taxi form maybe
just rocks III keeping this protected be
sure that's quite strong yeah it's
definitely stronger than this night so
what is the point I'm taking here Knight
b6 maybe it might be okay I think it's
probably better to to keep the night
dominated and try to maybe grab a
forward the king
yeah i was thinking that this might come
hmm can go to d3 or no good morning now
Bishop cheeks is also fine and I could
have played not be six that was a bit
better I think ok trying for rookie six
Jeff
let's take that black Rosell should
should help a bit yeah the bishop takes
22 was really shocking i really did not
expect that one coming okay ff5 is
already very very risky the computer
actually gives her gives a different
thing here the compounds to not take but
directly play a form and says what is
essentially winning this is a bit
surprising why is it so good Bishop
chains for Queen c3 and wide wins okay
okay i see the point the quincy three
years i mean those pieces here they are
very unlucky d placed something that
this is getting Knight f6 righted and so
that would have been even better okay I
took here okay here so he has to
preserve this piece go go back to to g7
and then the question is what i'm doing
i mean f4 was what i wanted to do okay
let's say something like this mmm yeah
that's not entirely clear why should be
somewhat better but it's not like he's
falling apart and the immediate f4 was
was definitely better yeah but this this
cannot be cannot be right giving up them
defending bishop down a g6 and ya f for
its may be debatable but i cannot
believe it's it's that it's bad okay I
can do that this gives like one pawn for
wide yeah rookie five is so only move
and here white is simply clearly better
in this in this end game type of
position takes them okay I could have
chicken c5 which I did not do hmm okay I
had this is McKenna's this looks very
good okay didn't see that one yeah
bishop a6 was betcha hmm I was thinking
of this should be good okay did it is
good but it's not winning maybe and I'm
here after this I'm probably winning
yeah this looks it looks bad okay the
comp points out this move this is this
may be a bit a bit tougher if Black gets
d5 hear me no but he doesn't right I
can't do this now again it's still
probably lost Jeff Kent after that he he
resigned we had them before the bionet
attack is some certainly a good line I
only play it occasionally and I'm not
really very young yeah knowledgeable but
ya want to try out things here and there
okay well thanks for watching